es ist die wahrscheinlich teuerste
skyline der welt fast zwei billionen
dollar sind nach angaben der new yorker
steuerbehörde allein hier in manhattan
angelegt in beton gold auch russlands
oligarchen haben in new york investiert
die metropole hat sich nicht lumpen
lassen und seiner tochter am central
park ein penthouse für 88 millionen
dollar gekauft für mehr als 90 millionen
hat roman abramowitsch seine ex frau und
den kindern gleich ein paar der
teuersten häuser in der upper east side
spendiert die häuser werden gerade
kernsaniert und baulich zusammengelegt
und damit die familien der zwischenzeit
auch standesgemäß unterkommt ziehen die
abramowitsch gleich um die ecke erstmal
beim oligarchen kollegen oleg deripaska
in dessen 42 millionen dollar behausung
in der vorgehaltener hand erzählen und
smarter dass die oligarchen szene nervös
geworden sei und manche versuchen würden
heimlich zu verkaufen denn es soll ihnen
jetzt auch hier in den usa an den kragen
gehen
unser justizministerium ist dabei eine
taskforce aufzubauen um die verbrechen
der russischen oligarchen zu verfolgen
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
verbündeten werden wir ihre yachten
luxus appartements und flugzeuge
beschlagnahmen wir kriegen euch und eure
schmutzigen profit
of pop wie man in amerika sagt eine
kampfansage die aber sei mehr
augenwischerei als klare kante wenn
überhaupt könne sie nur der anfang sein
das problem läge sehr viel tiefer
erklärt uns einer der seit jahren
oligarchen kapital aufspürt
was da gerade passiert ist heuchlerisch
in dem sinne dass wir das geld genommen
haben viele viele jahre war es ein sehr
lukratives geschäft für privatbanken
anwälte und beratungsfirmen der
sogenannten geldwäsche industrie
viel von diesem geld ist an die
erwartbaren orte geflossen nach new york
miami london aber auch deutschland
james henry vahl chefvolkswirt der
beratungsgesellschaft mckinsey er hat
das fbi und scotland yard beraten kennt
die tricks der verschleierung von
geldflüssen aus der ehemaligen
sowjetunion seien etwa 2000 milliarden
dollar in den westen gelangt die
beschlossenen sanktionen gegen die
oligarchen sei nur ein tropfen auf den
heißen stein
diese besonders spektakulären dinge wie
auch für ein kunstsammlungen und
fabelhaften central park west
appartements sind nur ein relativ
kleiner teil
das meiste geld liegt in anonymen
investments
die beschlagnahmung von yachten
privatflugzeugen und luxusimmobilien
sein anfang aber vor allem gut für die
pr das gros der gelder lege angelegt
über scheinfirmen auch in den größten
international operierenden immobilien
und investmentfonds oder gehe direkt im
große immobilienprojekte geld das auch
eingesetzt werden um unsere demokratien
zu destabilisieren
dieses geld hat putin an die macht
gebracht und die hat er sich durch das
oligarchen system bewahrt diese leute
stehen zu seiner verfügung er nutzt sie
für seine zwecke zum beispiel um
westliche politiker und ihre politik zu
beeinflussen
der aufstieg donald trumps ist ein
beispiel dafür
schon 2017 hatten wir über donald trumps
nähe zu russischen gangstern und
oligarchen und seiner wirtschaftlichen
abhängigkeit von ihnen berichtet
nach dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
war schon zunächst russische mafia
syndikate ihre gelder über trump
immobilien in new york kaufen unter
anderem appartements im trump tower
als er mehrmals bankrott geht springen
ihm immer wieder russischer oligarchen
zur seite mit den besten verbindungen in
den kreml
als tramp bei der einzigen bank die noch
geld leiht der deutschen bank eine
fällige kreditrate über 45 millionen
dollar nicht leisten kann hilft dimitri
murawjew aus kaufte rammt mitten in der
finanzkrise für über 95 millionen dollar
ein anwesen in florida ab dass der erst
kurz zuvor für weniger als die hälfte
erworben hatte
später beteiligt sie trump an einer
immobilien entwicklungs firma gegründet
mit geldern ungeklärter herkunft von
verurteilten gangstern betrügern und
oligarchen aus der ehemaligen
sowjetunion
es ist vor allem russisches geld das
ihnen wirtschaftlich immer wieder am
leben gehalten hat das ist gar keine
frage dass es ohne dieses geld donald
trump nicht möglich gewesen wäre 2016
für die us präsidentschaft zu
kandidieren
während des wahlkampfs dann koordiniert
sich james wahlkampfmanager pro männer
vor über einen russischen
geheimdienstagenten mit dem oligarchen
oleg deripaska einem engen vertrauten
von wladimir putin zu diesem schluss
kommt der geheimdienstausschuss des
us-senats in einem parteiübergreifenden
bericht
als präsident schließlich ist donald
trump dabei putins träume wahr werden zu
lassen er spaltet die usa immer tiefer
und will 2018 aus der nato austreten
erzählt und sein damaliger nationaler
sicherheitsberater john boden
wir alle du ihn begleitet haben haben
wirklich gedacht dass er kurz davor ist
den austritt zu verkünden und wir haben
hart daran gearbeitet das zu verhindern
er hat es dann nicht getan aber er hat
eine linie überschritten und klargemacht
dass er wirklich bereit ist es zu tun
uns hat große sorgen bereitet dass er es
in zukunft tun könnte in einer zweiten
amtszeit zum beispiel er wäre dann
wahrscheinlich ausgetreten
tausende milliarden dollar den
russischen bürgern gestohlen angelegt
über anonyme tarnfirmen im westen in
obszönen luxus und politische
einflussnahme wir müssen endlich damit
beginnen richtig aufzuräumen wenn wir es
ernst meinen mit dem schutz unserer
demokratien meint james henry denn die
politische einflussnahme gehe weit über
donald trump hinaus und er machte einen
ebenso radikalen die pragmatischen
vorschlag
ich schlage vor dass wir uns kurzfristig
überlegen alle anonymen anlagen
einzufrieren wer dann daran will muss
persönlich erscheinen und die herkunft
des geldes erklären das ist eine taktik
die man in italien bei der mafia
angewendet hat und sie war sehr
erfolgreich
fest steht sanktionen gegen einzelne
oligarchen werben das problem allein
nicht lösen
schmutziges geld gewaschen über banken
anwälte und beratungsfirmen hier bei uns
im westen